it's genius really and always keep in
mind
the games companies that publicly bend
the knee to you and your activism
those ones are keepers and they should
be protected at all times
so that everyone else can learn from
them so be sure to give
this this this was one of the okay so
this is something i wanted to get into
just for a little bit
today um
this last of us thing i don't understand
why people like this game
okay i i played the first one so this is
not
this isn't like me coming into something
that i haven't played i played the first
one
the first last of us game was okay
it was okay it was an okay game i would
it was not mind-blowing
it was not any it was all it was an
alright game
i don't never understood the [ __ ]
hype honestly parts of the game were
boring
i just whatever fine last of us too
i haven't played it okay
i have watched a lot of videos on it
because i'm trying to go how is it
ten out of ten that's a [ __ ] good
game jesus christ the game must be good
and i've even watched some videos of
that
today i think if you're on twitch right
now i'm still it still says i'm
streaming last of us too
um
i don't understand
what the [ __ ] obsession is it seems
like a typical
zombie slash third person
shooter i don't understand it what's so
deep about this game and if people tell
me oh it's the story the story is
amazing the story is the
it's it has the depth of a season five
walking dead episode
so it's not even like it's a depth it's
story in depth and it's like oh wow
like you want to even if you're one of
those you want a story with a good
you want a game with a good story that i
mean the gameplay
it's basically a movie but you know you
you you select some of the outcome like
you want to play a game with a good
story that i was like man that was
actually really cool that was fun
for the playstation play heavy rain
heavy rain is very good heavy rain is
better than this and better than the
other last of us one
and i understand that it's not a shooter
i understand heavy rain is just kind of
a little short choose your own adventure
thing
but i actually really enjoyed that
but this is [ __ ] there's another
thank you atlas report you want another
game with a with a good story that's
actually fun to play that's not just
your typical [ __ ] zombie shooter
go play bioshock series go play the
bioshock series
all of them are good um detroit thank
you jay jason there's another one
um but
but i don't get this 10 a 10 out of 10
10
why why because these [ __ ] game
sites all that matters is that it's
brave
it's that it's [ __ ] brave jj did you
did you play last of us too
i i i think you made you told me you did
did you play last of us two
is it 10 out of 10 i trust jj stoner jj
stoner is is like my
my go-to gaming guy um
i do actually trust his opinion when it
comes to games
um not so much music but
i will say last of us two was a smooth
game i'm fine but that's not what i'm
asking
is it a 10 out of 10 game
eight out of ten at best i will accept
that
but we know why they got those extra two
points right
they got those extra two points because
they were being woke and they had
sex if it wasn't for the train sex and
if it wasn't for elliot page's forehead
nobody would care about this game nobody
would care
so i don't understand it i am having
so much more fun playing cyberpunk it's
crazy
as a matter of fact i have cyberpunk for
xbox one and yes it does not look that
great on xbox one i
will say that but but see that shows you
what how for me what a good game
cyberpunk is right
obviously it has this glitch it has his
issues especially on the older consoles
and stuff um but even with that i still
have enjoyed playing it so much so
that i got it on this compute this
computer is a bad boy this computer can
play the game ultra 4k
the one i'm streaming on now the i9
whatever it's [ __ ] badass
so i also got last of us on this
computer
at some point i think i'll probably do
some streaming of it and playing a
different
on this computer at some point it's not
going to be during shows it'll just be
when i'm bored and i want to do a stream
on the day wave channel probably um if
you guys want to check that out
but i've enjoyed i've enjoyed that game
way more than the first last of us for
sure
and any for everything i've seen of last
of us too has seen watching people play
it
um i don't understand it
i i really i really don't i don't get it
but i am still i know it has its bugs
and i get that and i go the game
probably shipped the ship like a to be
honest with you cd projekt pulled the
bethesda game but that's the ship with a
bunch of bugs a bunch of [ __ ]
i really i really enjoyed cyberpunk
i'm enjoying it i haven't beat it yet i
mean i mean i think 23 hours in
uh and that that's that's a fun game but
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] last of us
look man everyone likes what they want
right but no one's gonna [ __ ]
convince me
nobody is going to convince me
that the reason that that that last of
us too is
is is not eight out of ten but ten out
of ten is because of its wokeness i'm
sorry
nobody absolutely nobody
my turbo graphics 16 still works hey but
keep it probably could sell for
i know you're kidding but you probably
have a lot of money
so uh yeah anyway that's my
that's my take on that can we stop
saying woke
you're not gonna like some of the
christmas songs i have today then um
you have a better term for it because if
you have a better term for it i'll
happily use it but i've
haven't really seen one um
ghost tsunami hurt is really good i
haven't played it but my point is not
even that well you like games whether
you don't my point is is that it's this
this [ __ ]
this this um i'm using it again this
woke-ism
is exactly why
so wokism is working in tandem with the
reviewers and all that stuff and i'm not
breaking any ground you know comic
skating gamergate i understand that this
isn't me
[ __ ] saying something that people
don't know it's a fact but i think it's
worth repeating
at least in my opinion i think it's
worth repeating that
this is the reason we're getting shitty
games this is the reason that we're
getting shitty movies
this is the reason that we're getting
shitty tv shows this is the reason why
this is the reason we're we're getting
shitty youtube streams because any of
the good ones
get kicked off it's because
they want to push their ideology so bad
that they will overlook they will
overlook if a game is good
if it's fun all they care about is that
it's woke
like critical drinker was saying more
more [ __ ] people cared
these [ __ ] game journalists more
people cared about the fact that you
could put it
on on a chick or on a dude in cyberpunk
then they [ __ ] even cared about the
game
[ __ ] nobody nobody [ __ ] cared
about that
nobody cared about the fact that you
know the game is fun and a cool story
and
you know the fighting is fun and all
that stuff all they care about
it's i'm so [ __ ] sick of this like
everything